- Coffee Coolatta.
(claps rhythmically)
- Might be horchata.
- It's the Pumpkin Spice Latte.
(claps)
- We are testing Pumpkin
Spice Latte hacks.
- I drink Starbucks
when I'm feeling bougie.
- I feel like Starbucks
will make anything for you,
like you can say whatever you want
and they'll make anything.
- I don't understand what
the pumpkin spice is.
- If you like bottled up
like white girls in UGG boots
as a flavor, it would be pumpkin spice.
- I am actually really
excited to try these.
(mellow marimba music)
- This visually looks very interesting.
- Yeah, visually this is,
- Yeah.
- Wonderful.
- It's like ombre.
- This looks like a candy corn coffee.
- I hate candy corn.
- Yeah, get some of that action.
- Oh wow.
- Oh whoa.
- This is kinda good, it
kinda tastes like cinnamon-ey.
- When you first sip it,
it tastes like coffee,
but then it has that like
pumpkin spice aftertaste.
- All I taste is like
caramel and sugar and milk.
- I'm a maybe, I'm looking
forward to the rest.
- I'm giving this two thumbs up.
(classical music)
- Willy Wonka just like shit this out.
Like this is an insane
amount going on here.
- Oh my God, it's really good.
- I don't like it.
- I don't taste any coffee.
- Oh that's just like
straight-up chocolate chips.
- I'm gonna give it a thumbs down.
It's just really sweet.
- Yeah.
(mellow rock music)
- This really sounds,
smells, and looks like
a drinkable Yankee candle.
- Yeah.
- I love this.
- Right?
I'm all about this.
- This is so good.
- It tastes like apple
cider and applesauce,
put together.
- It hits you in the face, you're like.
- [Woman In Turban] It smacks ya.
- Out of all the drinks so far,
this one feels the most like fall.
(upbeat music)
- Oh, this smells so good.
- This does not look that appealing.
- Have we been tricked?
Is there even any pumpkin in this?
- Where is the pumpkin?
- Yeah.
- It's actually not that
bad, it just tastes like
a regular hot chocolate
with like a hint of pumpkin.
- I like it a lot, it's a good mix.
- Yeah.
(classical music)
- We both liked the Caramel Apple Spice.
- I enjoyed the Caramel
Apple Pumpkin Spice the most.
I don't think I would personally order it
but if offered one, I
would not turn it down.
- The iced one is good
because it has coffee in it
but you can also still
taste like the pumpkin.
- The hot chocolate was
great because it just tasted
like hot chocolate with a little kick,
like a little spice to it.
- Right.
- I was a big judger of
the Pumpkin Spice Latte.
After these hacks, pretty into it.
I'm like, I can fuck
with some pumpkin spice.
- Keep doing your thing, pumpkins.
- Yes.
- Pumpkin Spice Latte.
(both clap rhythmically)
- Where the drink's at,
where the drink's at,
where the drink's at.
(classical music)